cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
pris samedi soir il lui a relevé un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher
d'eux a pu conserver son automate le
moyen sans même accueilli
[Musique]
non
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'art dimat
comme vous le savez j'ai pris un pari
fou auprès de la direction de la chaîne
celui de vous tenir en haleine tous les
samedis soirs pendant une heure
si vous zappez si je ne fais pas assez
dardy maths je suis dit vrai
[Musique]
pour éviter ça à ma femme et à mes
enfants j'ai à ma disposition tout ce
qui a été tourné depuis l'invention de
la caméra je me suis également adjoint
les services d'un expert rester les
visions le professeur rollin que
certains d'entre vous connaissent déjà
professeur la bon soir
j'ai par ailleurs demandé à deux
téléspectateur moyen d'être présent sur
le plateau d'or du mat
ils peuvent réagir quand il le désire
irène bonsoir passé jean pierre et moi
très bien merci
les autres c'est-à-dire vous chez vous
vous pouvez également réagir en appelant
le 36 65 71 23
voilà je sais que ce dispositif me
permettra de faire exploser leurs 10
matchs et grâce à vous nous allons
traiter non non non non non thierry non
non je vais moi de vous couper dans
votre élan mais enfin vous n'arriverez à
rien comme ça enfin franchement qu'est
ce que c'est que ce cinéma là qu'est ce
que c'est que cette emphase ridicule
qu'est ce que c'est que ce décorum
pompiers vous croyez que vous allez vous
rendre sympathique avec ce déballage
mussolinien se présente oui mais parce
qu'il est là le problème
thierry les gens ne vous trouve pas
sympathique tous les sondages on a
encore un peu les yeux toutes les
enquêtes le montrent vous avez une
mauvaise image dans le public les gens
le disent quand on les interroge ils
disent s'ils maîtrisent mois les
sondages le montrent les gens disent les
gens disent il ya une chose qu'on n'aime
pas dans les émission d'ardisson c'est
ardisson j'y peux rien c'est comme ça
prouve et ab justement vous tombez bien
thierry parce que la chaîne a fait
préparer un micro trottoir pour vous le
démontrer si vous voulez jeter un oeil
prenez votre petit téléviseur regarder
mon regard est ce que tu connais thierry
ardisson oui j'aime bien non provocateur
et il m'énerve quand on sait que tu peux
lui dire là qu'il est antipathique
oui je peux vas-y mais je vais pas me
gêner thierry très antipathique way
salut chips pourquoi tu trouves ardisson
antipathique saurait j'aime pas du tout
va tellement il fait un pays dit un peu
trop de conneries je trouve il critique
un peu trop il veut et fait jouer aux
grands tout ça devant tout les gens tous
avant tout le monde
il veut se la donner quoi c'est un peu
le beau ouais voilà il fait un peu le
beau exactement l'impression qu'il est
franc j'ai l'impression qu'il est froid
mais qu'il en fait un peu trop quel
niveau bas il est sûr de lui il se veut
francs mais bon je sais pas s'il est
franchement mais complètement fond je
crois qu'il est un peu faux cul oui
surtout dans sa façon de rire
son sourire est pas francs voilà je
n'étais son sourire c'est surtout ça
c'est quoi son sourire
will est pas naturelle g bassila sourire
crispé
ça vous déplaît oui complètement
il sourit un vote revêtement béton rien
peu trop vêtements feuillerie on sent
qu'il est parfois gênés quoi très joli
sourire
tout est bien fait quoi je veux dire
tout est bien refait ouais à mon avis
c'est bien fait rien qui te déplaît
chalut six royalistes j'aime pas non je
trouve odieux
il a un physique quand tu trouves qu'il
est trop payèrent dix ans je sais pas
combien les pays plein de 0.20 bah tant
mieux pour lui qu'il en profitera
peut-être pas durer mais qu'est-ce que
je peux faire au moins deux sympathiques
mois écoutez le terrible prenons les
problèmes dans l'ordre regardons le
premier reproche les gens disent qu'ils
rient ardisson et lointains par le faux
souris faux je n'ai pas assez proche des
gens brown a deuxième reproche on dit
ardisson n'est pas généreux on dit le
rôle pour ça qu'ils en savent les gens
les gens le disent thierry yeux moi je
regarde les enquêtes je vous demande pas
de commandes brutes et chaque point les
gens disent ils s'intéressent qu'à lui
même il se fiche du rêve à votre place
je ferais un geste là encore pour
montrer que vous avez un coeur coin dont
par exemple moi je fais un don
thierry vous prenez les français pour
des imbéciles en dont ils semblent sûrs
sur un plateau télévisé le prenez pour
des idiots alors on dit je fais un don
et puis dans 25 minutes on ira tous
dépensées en boîtes de nuit
si vous voulez faire un don regardez les
gens et fait un don maintenant en direct
devant tout le monde
bon mais comme importe comme importe mon
carnet de chèques s'il vous plaît il est
dans la dans la poche de mon imperméable
vous allez donner à qui faut que je vous
le disais qu'ils donnent sinon office et
si c'est pour me donner à moi thierry ça
s'appelle prague ont coûté je vais
donner à la paroisse de man de mon
quartier voilà c'est un philippe du
roule catholique je sais pas si c'est ce
que vous avez trouvé de mieux pour vous
rendre systématique ma faim donnez
donnez donnez alesi très très discutée
pas parce que sinon on va y passer deux
heures il donnera rien du tout vous
allez donnez combien 10000 sécurité
jusqu'à 15000 mais en fait devenus des
mille feuilles non rapport à ce que vous
gagnez ce qui met 15 bis leur a été fait
juste mon enfant donné dix mille ok bah
écoute et thierry je crois qu'on a déjà
un petit peu remonté la pente en tout
cas j'espère oui à ce prix là voilà je
vous laisse poursuivre l'émission je
crois qu'on est mieux là mon image
à mon sens ça s'améliore attendait tout
le travail ne sera pas en un jour
parce qu'on vient de loin loin loin loin
loin je dois vous remercier
je suis là pour vous donner des conseils
ou versa j'ai mon expérience 1 encore un
mot avant de commencer ses émissions
j'aime beaucoup les chiens
il y en a dans l'équipe d'ares d'imad
que tout le monde adore vous le voyez en
ce moment sur votre écran il s'appelle
zappe
je les aime beaucoup moi aussi je dois
vous dire que si l'art d'imad descend en
dessous de 15%
nous serons obligés de tuer ce chien je
ne pas le chantage c'est comme ça
comme vous le savez tf avait coutume de
diffuser le samedi soir l'excellente
émission de nicolas hulot ushuaïa
mais désormais tf1 diffuse le samedi
soir à cette heure-là un téléfilm
américain ce soir visage de tueurs je
vous le dis monsieur mougeotte
je te le dis etienne c'est pas sympa ça
[Musique]
si le jeu si le jeu c'est de diffuser
des séries américaines tout le monde
peut le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la série les envahisseurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
avec wright qui naissent dans le rôle de
david vincent
diane bérard oui je sais président oui
je sais service public lui le service
public je sais où
oui pas de séries américaines à par
deezer stone les vestes europe hockey et
des séries françaises avec eux kouchner
non ok politique
oui thierry je comprends la réaction de
la chaîne assez normal ya là un problème
de déontologie avons déjà peut-être une
autre solution vous savez plutôt que
d'essayer d'attirer la clientèle est
chez nous sur cette chaîne
on peut peut-être tout simplement la
décourager d'aller sur l'autre chaîne et
en faisant quoi bein peut-être en leur
racontant la fin de la série en question
a pas mal vous la connaissez
ab ou bien entendu mesdames messieurs
doit bien sûr je vais vous raconter la
fin du téléfilm visage de tueurs qui
passe en ce moment sur tf1 celui que
l'on prend pour l'assassin le jeune
policier n'est en fait qu'un pigeon et
locales wii est le commanditaire de
l'assassinât est autre que le chef de la
police à la fin deux visages de tueurs
en ce moment sur tf1
le gentil professeur dé ce cas là dessus
le chef de la police après une course
poursuite sur la façade du building
voilà donc vous pouvez rester sur france
2 puisque vous connaissez la fin du
téléfilm de tf1
que faire
himat tout est possible un terreau du
truc et reality show film de cul mais
pour faire de l'art dit matt il faut
savoir traiter sobrement de l'actualité
quitte à faire réfléchir les gens
sarajevo
quels sont aujourd'hui les risques réels
d'une guerre mondiale
sarajevo dimanche 28 juin 1914
tout commence l'archiduc
françois-ferdinand héritier du trône
d'autriche hongrie et son épouse tombent
sous les balles du jeune étudiant
bastillac gavino prennent 6
[Musique]
ce drame frappe douloureusement le vieil
empereur françois joseph dont les
espoirs s'écroule l'empereur d'allemagne
guillaume ii donne son appui total à
françois joseph deux jours après la
déclaration de guerre de l'autriche à la
serbie la russie mobilise le 30 juillet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier roues c'est au tour de la
france de décréter la mobilisation
générale
en même temps que l'allemagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le trajet c'est la guerre et les
allemands pénètre en belgique
leucate où l'angleterre entre elles
aussi dans le conflit tout est consommé
et cinq semaines après sarajevo
la première guerre mondiale de
l'histoire est déclenché
[Musique]
nul ne sait alors qu'elle durera quatre
ans il fera 7 millions de morts
[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
vous venez d'assister aux prémices de la
première guerre mondiale
passons maintenant à ceux de la deuxième
ouais ouais ouais bien vieux bossis
j'ai rarement vu un garçon faire un
match comme lui ce soir
[Applaudissements]
mais que se passe-t-il
mais regardez regardez schumacher s'est
carrément de l'agression ah là là là
voilà du football comme on n'aimerait
pas voir le gic paul arbitres de touche
devez le signaler
ce geste de schumacher est tout à fait
inadmissible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lots de responsabilité
regardez encore l'action une fois au
ralenti schumacher arrivé c'est
délibérément il fonde en batiste ont un
côté le ballon visiblement il se passe
quelque chose
platini a l'air inquiet baptista retour
au sol et basse et michel hidalgo qui
vient ou laurel michel un qui est son
visage des mauvais jours
la civière qui arrive mais ça doit être
très grave
l'amitié franco-allemande enfants
écoutent
[Applaudissements]
et oui il faut courir messieurs cours et
mathis tour souffre sur cette pelouse de
douleur c'est absolument anti sportif
est scandaleux rené harvey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel hidalgo toujours inquiets
larbitre la siffler probablement un
penalty on le serait à moins
[Musique]
colère le michel colère
voilà des humains qu'on voudrait
j'avais pu voir platini pic à la même
son copain battiston qui souffre
76% des français sont partisans d'une
intervention en bosnie mais on ne sait
pas combien sont d'accord à condition
que ce soit le fils du voisin qui parle
on ne sait pas encore combien serons
d'accord quand la télé montrera les
mamans accompagnant leurs enfants sur le
port de toulon
quand la télé montrera le retour des
premiers cercueil attention ces départs
à la guerre c'est toujours plus beau au
cinéma
[Musique]
en amour je
attendre et août
si je
penserai
toi
[Musique]
je pense
[Applaudissements]
non
oui
encore
m'éloigner de temps
[Musique]
bah
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chut
[Musique]
au cinéma mais la guerre à la télé c'est
comment bien avant celle du golfe
pendant celle des malouines
jean luc godard se demandait déjà s de
l'info s de l'intox
cdi à main je passais dans la rue là
j'ai entendu une photo que j'ai dit ça y
est ça repart pas trop je suis prêt non
tu as entendu info intox mais enfin
double jeu c'est fini philippe est
enroulé un bail à la wii et les scores
non j'ai un truc je t'appelle ah ouais
t'es jeune parent moi je jodoigne par la
cortisone
allez à bientôt philippe harrouard salut
ouf corti jean luc godard vos réflexions
sur cet événement
mais vous avez bien fait parce que vous
avez besoin de moi pour pour dialoguer
c'est difficile avec vous à la télé vous
parlez beaucoup vous montrer quelques
images ces pauvres qui peuvent prendre
en dire grand chose j'ai regardé par
exemple hier une miss fin au journal il
y avait un petit documentaire vous avez
fait vous vous interview vielles des
anglais et je pense même pas qu'on peut
le revoir ici ça nous avec tout votre
matériel vous devez même pas pouvoir
revoir une image que vous avez montré
hier
bien sûr que si on peut ainsi voir
forcément celle là vous nous l'avez
demandé à plus tard la en direct oui un
peu tard car oui non peut pas travailler
moi je travaille avec des images et ce
qui m'intéresse
s'il fait à la télévision ça serait de
me servir des images pour voir quelque
chose mais le sine die comme i 12 ou
paulsen je sais pas il faut pas tuer
avec des mots mais c'est un mot en plus
et on ne se sert pas des trucs et la
panne en pierre c'est une ce que je
voulais vous dire ça m'a fait réfléchir
il y avait des vieux et des jeunes les
vieux étaient pour en découdre et tué
les jeunes disaient ça me rend malade
il y avait un jeune anglais qui parlait
un peu cook n'est qu'ils disaient
écoutez c'est quand même lamentable on a
fourni aux argentins des armes pour
torturer
leur peuple il ya trois quatre ans
maintenant ils les retourne contre nous
on veut les battre et en plus
on achète des armes à la france ou des
trucs tout ça ça me rend malade il
disait un peu et il est au chômage en
plus et c'était les gens qui étaient au
chômage sans travail qui disait une
certaine vérité les autres ils voulaient
en découdre
là il y avait deux images qui vous
voulez elles étaient elles étaient
baissées les deuxièmes c'est ça qu'il
faut montrer dans dans 4 jours vous
saurez si les commandes aux anglais
tiennent ou tiennent pas ça serait
intéressant d'y être aujourd'hui avec
vos moyens
ben non parce que jean luc godard sait
très bien que les moyens ce sont ceux
que les militaires britanniques ou
argentins peuvent laisser à des
journalistes que c'est de faire leur
travail et vous vous doutez bien que les
envoyés spéciaux de la télé de toute
télévision sauf la télévision
britannique ne sont pas présents sur le
lieu des combats c'est la guerre sur luc
godard la moins film et du monde
souhaiteriez si les pets sur le lieu des
combats
c'est mon métier et sinon la non mais
vous souhaiteriez vous moi
personnellement moi je crois que j'ai
personnellement comme métier mais je
crois j'ai eu ma dose de guerre comme
tout reporter qui longe la est de
montrer la guerre en direct vous pensez
moi je pense pas qu'on puisse la montée
en direct bien passionnerait les gens et
on y vient et on y vient les jeux du
cirque et la guerre est faite pour
passer à la télévision dans trois jours
dans trois jours vous en parlerai plus
comme le niger mais vous taisez vous
présentais ça fait sept semaines qu'on
parle des malouines jean luc godard tous
les jours ou presque on en parle
lamballe dix ans dans trois semaines
mais dans trois semaines quelqu'un qui
peut vous dire que pouvez vous dire sur
ce qui se passera dans le monde en trois
semaines jean-luc mais l'a pour
l'instant ce que je peux dire je peux
pas rien vous dire sur les malouines
parce que je suis à vous et de
l'exprimer
si si vous êtes exposés mais nous savons
pas non plus ce qui se passe mais c'est
peut-être déjà une information pourquoi
vous le dites pas fait les payes vous
commencez pas votre journal en disant je
ne sais pas j'ai commencé mon journal
jean luc en disant informations
contradictoires et confuse l'argentine
d'une chance des flandres autre chose
informations contradictoires où ils
avaient l'air de savoir que ces
informations contradictoires
dites moi chef d'antenne 2 je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe d'abord je ne suis
pas chauvin tenant premières
informations
deuxièmement master
je ne suis pas celui qui renonce à lui
parce qu au moment des faits ce n'est
pas une bonne définition speaker jean
luc godard je n'ai pas vu ce qui s'est
passé aux malouines ça vous convient pas
vous satisfaire
kb merci jean luc mais restez avec nous
parce que le dialogue est intéressant
agresseur l'a enfin se passe pas trop
mal pour l'instant avec cependant un
point noir au niveau des jeunes
voilà en effet une demi heure que
l'émission ait commencé et on n'a
toujours pas entendu une note de musique
résultat une hémorragie alarmante de
notre clientèle des 15 24 ans notamment
notamment au nord de la loire lesquels
15 24 ans représentent quand même je
vous le rappelle 47 et demi pour cent de
parts de marché sur le créneau des
marchands de cartables et des
réparateurs de sonnex
alors je crois qu'il faut réagir très
rapidement mais la musique michael
jackson serait il atteint à son tour par
le virus bruel il veut faire de sa
nouvelle chanson un hymne au mondial
pour qu'il n'y ait plus jamais de guerre
et que tous les gens soient heureux pour
toujours
voici in the world en france est soigné
le monde
numéro deux au top 50
m
[Musique]
promis
merci
[Musique]
p
m
[Musique]
alors ça vous plaît pas c'est pas moi ça
fait sa une de mur qu'on est là on peut
on n'a rien pu dire encore bah oui je
pensais de quoi on était venu là pour ça
on en rit mais de rester à la maison on
aurait téléphoné ç'aurait été pareil un
paradoxe vous demande votre avis quand
même on avait beaucoup de choses la
classe a conséquemment malaisie bah je
sais pas cette saman de commander 2
n'est pas très concernés c'est ce à quoi
je pense ça touche pas les gens vraiment
bien ça chez les gens simon et les infos
c'est pas mal mais ces giboulées faut
viser large quoi on a eu une petite faut
que ça fonctionne plus plus accessible
monde font que ce soit qui ait le tout
public quoique si vous voulez en même
temps en même temps il faut que ça reste
de qualité que ça bah ouais c'est si
vous voulez c'est vrai ouais c'est ce à
quoi on est on est également que ce soit
vous que ça touche les gens pour moi que
c'est faudrait que les gens se sentent
complètement entraîné quoi conserver
voilà mais que ce soit l'argent bien sûr
mais ça soit que ce soit que ce soit
fort entre accessoires bah oui c'est si
vous voulez il faut quand même temps c
ils sont allés trop loin quand même non
plus ghazi ça mais je vois bien salée de
la poisse est passé tout est bon c'est
parce que là on est un petit peu
bref bien 6 2 merci merci beaucoup
professeur will thierry je crois que
c'est très clair un j'entends ces
observations je crois qu'il ya très
clairement de la part du téléspectateur
une demande très forte dans le sens de
la qualité
oui alors c'est prévu c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous allons diffuser
maintenant un documentaire culturel
assure la ville de venise et ses musées
seulement dans la mesure où le
téléspectateur n'a pas encore le niveau
intellectuel suffisant pour regarder ce
document dans son intégralité non
chiffrée nos enquêtes le montrent nous
allons diffuser 29 secondes cette
semaine 1 et puis la semaine prochaine
par contre lorsque les téléspectateurs
seront habitués lors que leur niveau
aura un petit peu augmenté
on pourra en diffuse et 43 secondes et
puis ainsi de suite en augmentant de
semaine en semaine jusqu'à ce qu'ils
puissent le voir en entier
voilà
le grand canal font venise d'ouest en
est large et profonde cassure en forme
de s s comme sérénissime et tout au long
de ce grand canal côte à côte
s'appuyant les uns sur les autres les
palets s'alignent dans une harmonie
nullement altérée par la variété des
styles dans ça vous va cesser c'est
toujours pareil c'est même trop long
trop courant des forces populaires de
qualité non oui oui c'est aller dans ce
sens professeur vient je crois que
j'enregistre la satisfaction de nos amis
irène et jean-pierre je crois que le
service public a rempli sa mission alors
en revanche en ce qui concerne les
chiffres ça ne va pas fort fort fort et
je commence à avoir une petite
inquiétude pour le chien notre petit ap
me semble très légèrement menacée je
crois qu'il serait temps si vous avez
quelque chose de fort si vous avez
quelque chose qui puisse un petit peu
new way faire repartir c'est le moment
thierry j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
professeur voulez un scoop
j'arrive tout plein c'est ce qu'il faut
pour faire monter lardy macgé
l'interview exclusive de l'assassin de
john lennon mick chapman
ce n'est pas les notes que j'ai voulu
tuer dit il
une pochette de 10 en fait il voulait
être aussi célèbre que celui qui avait
déclaré être aussi célèbres que le
christ mac chapman
[Musique]
j'ai entendu cette voix pas une voix
claire mais une voix imperceptible qui
me disait encore et encore
vas-y fais-le vas-y c'était à
l'intérieur de moi
[Musique]
j'ai sorti de revolver de ma poche
j'étais dans tous mes états j'ai levé le
revolver je les sers est très fort de ma
main gauche et j'ai tiré cinq coups
réguliers dans son dos à ce moment là
pour moi
faux mais c'était la fin du film
j'étais assis là pendant quelques
minutes
et puis du coin de l'oeil j'ai vu cette
silhouette s'approchait de la fenêtre de
la voiture
ces tuyaux qu elle a regardé je les
regardais j'ai été foudroyé par son
regard
elle cherchait à comprendre à savoir
mais qui est ce monstre ignoble qui
vient de tuer john lennon
mon mari je veux voir sera ce [ __ ]
peur
aller au guichet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de tuer john lennon j'ai imploré
sept ans de me venir en aide
parce que je savais que tout seul je
n'arriverai pas à tuer un homme
j'ai suivi une sorte de rituel pour
devenir une créature de satan j'ai
enlevé tous mes vêtements et j'ai crié
j'ai pousser des hurlements
[Musique]
je dois vous dire comment m'est venue
l'idée de tuer john lennon début j'étais
à la bibliothèque et je suis tombé sur
le livre d'anthony facettes et les one
day time et j'ai appris dans ce livre
qu'il vivait dans un coin ultra chic de
manhattan et s'est même mis hors de moi
ce que je sais c'est que je ne savais
pas désespérer vider de tout sens assure
un super moins que rien face à cette
grande personnalité que je pense est
bidon pas français moi le moins que rien
je voulais à battre cette personnalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
invite 7 et créant ainsi profond que
j'ai cru quand le tour je deviendrai
aussi célèbre que lui
je vous en prie yoko essayer de
comprendre ce n'était pas un être humain
que j'ai voulu tuer c'est une image que
je voulais tuer la couverture d'un album
arbres cave
professeur thierry je constate que vous
avez fait un gros effort vous avez tiré
ce document exclusif une de vos
meilleures cartouches pourtant
l'hémorragie continue tous les
clignotants sont dans le rouge
et là je dois vous dire que je ne donne
pas bien cher de l'avenir du petit chien
ap
c'est pas croyable je ne sais plus ce
qu'on peut faire bah si ben quoi
super joker si on peut m'envoyer super
joker s'il vous plaît
et
ah bah oui vite et dans toutes les
émissions de télé super joker celui qui
fait monter l'audience
j'en ai fait la profession après ça y
est je suis la profession invité donc
super joker tu fais monter les animals
et j'arrive à temps parce que c'est la
dégringolade est un professeur on était
pourtant j'ai quoi je vais marcher
normalement jusqu ici je pense chargé
jean fait pas des tonnes
je reste peut-être mais voilà super
joker si vous pouvez faire quelque chose
pour nous non alors là il mate way but
l'hémorragie faut un garrot la folie
sorel non je sais c'est pas c'est pas
valorisant pour l'émission mais ça fait
ses preuves sur d'autres chaînes et je
crois que l'histoire drôle la blague à
la con quoi le truc débile
alors bon bah j'espère que vous la
connaissez pas si vous la connaissez je
compte sur vous le dites ria c'est ses
deux éléphantes qui sont dans la jambe
qui a qui s'en va la connaître et ça ne
rigole d'avancé donc ses grands super
duke et ça et ce deux éléphants qui sont
leurs agents et il y en a elles vont
près d'un lac
et puis il y en a une qui va puis qui se
baignent dans l'eau et elle est là elle
sa rose elle s'éclate et tout ça puis à
l'autre et défendent qui restent près de
la berge comme ça et puis l'autre une
limite est folle mais tu es folle mais
vieux sellin fraîchissant tu devrais te
baigner avec moi l'hôtellerie mais non
je peux pas j'ai mes ragnagnas retenue
mais [ __ ] mais fait comme moi mais un
mouton
cette idiotie
et c'est consternant mais c'est efficace
ou alors là non l'histoire pour rester
un peu dans le service public si vous
voulez ça je suis moins sur un mât mon
histoire et leurs dates pour vous
connaissez ça monsieur et madame camille
non un fils ouais sim
c'est une gamine attendait monsieur et
madame bidart ont une fille
hervé revient pas dans ces cas là je
vais me lancer à la fois remonté les
manches référence kadja au boulot un
super joker way
[Applaudissements]
j'ai essayé un truc sympa c'est les
vacances
c'est une agence de voyage qui m'a
conseillé bien sûr le catalogue avait
marqué koumac beau pays pas cher le
billet d'abord bon voyage sur une
compagnie qui s'appelle chartered en
apportant pognon 45 heures de vol paris
bruxelles bruxelles londres londres
barcelone barcelone los angeles los
angeles grenoble grenoble koumac et
quand arrive là-bas la première chose
que tu fais tu dors forcément faut que
tu récupères j'ai dormi 77 eur je me
suis réveillé à mercredi à minuit
j'avais une autre patate d'enfer
seulement ni nuit là bas il ya rien à
faire un tout est fermé
non parce qu'on y douze heures de
décalage horaire mais point de vue
niveau de vie il ya trois siècles de
décalage horaire pendant une semaine je
me suis réveillé à minuit les nuits sont
belles longues mais belle mais l'ong
et puis j'étais malade j'ai perdu 12
kilos non mais c'est de ma faute j'ai
fait une connerie j'ai bu un verre d'eau
non mais c'est ma faute la connerie quoi
la bassée soda quinine sol d'actine en
boîte whisky qui mine mais qui nie il
faut pas s'amuser à bram alcool local
une le boivent toi tu le mets dans ta
mobylette qui monte à 160
et il a le goût demande pas ce qui
rajoute du canard wc le tél bien oui
attention la photo de l'hôtel sur le
prospectus c'est le projet la plage elle
existe au nord de l'hôtel à 50 km de
brousse de toute façon ça sert à rien de
content km faut compter en heures un
kilomètre de brousse ça fait une heure
voilà la plage tu par la veille mais
quand tu arrives là bas bien soleil
prison il tape bien 40 degrés à l'ombre
là bas il n'y a pas d'ombré d'abord le
soleil c'est pas ton ami la basse et
crème solaire à vis de protection 18-20
xl xxl tee shirt manches longues en
coton parce qu'on n'a pas le niveau
grâce à fond ça brûle et puis la mer
bleue puis chaude et pas de requins
trois dangereux semaine par les requins
du coup mer dangereuse soleil agressif
alcool nocifs
tu visites forcément koumac tu visites
pas par plaisir vraie nature celle
d'avant hostile la barre des 10 avec des
cuissardes oublie les rangers non parce
qu'il est scorpion ça dort dans les
rangers ça
et alors ça le sommeil léger à peine tu
mets le pied tu te réveilles puis sera
donc pas de bon poil c'est pas du matin
de scorpions de toute façon - les
rangers ce jeu pouvait plus les maîtres
après la première piqûre chaussée du 82
je m'étais plus d adidas pas les
chaussures et les sacs de sport austin
la nature hostile la nature je sais de
vous le faire un hostie donateurs je
retrouve à huy ah oui à l'âge ensuite
invité je me méfie des moustiques
j'avais mené la citronnelle erreur point
lance-flammes livré moustiques gros
comme des libellules à côté des
scorpions c'est peace and love ait
appuyé par le moustique lamari temps
pâle il te tournes 3200 chaque voyage
oui mon chapeau aux pectoraux j'avais
les 5 samantha fox
avec mais adidas au pied ya en remontant
qui est tombé à - 2 mois et l'ours à
l'orang outan tu dis oui une fois il
prend la balle benoît costil la nature
par contre le retour tout seul dans
l'avion mais le luxe tout le monde au
petit soin pour toi à jouer et j'aurais
plus qu avec europ assistance
[Applaudissements]
à 20 heures
énorme succès du côté des agriculteurs
les courbes sont en flèche vers le haut
un petit peu moins bien chez les
détaillants pathé ouais bon résultat
quand même normal quand on a un nouvelle
calédonie fabriquons pas tu es bon ben
il décroche c'est pas la mer pourcentage
l'art dimaté bon mieux que ça au parfait
je vous dois à combien super chacun 40
secondes à 40 goals en bas oui j'suis
pas donner quoi
non mais il y en a qui sont moins chers
les love amour carlos dans les
prochaines quarante secondes à la bombe
allez-y faites vos 40 secondes super
joker
merci vous me laissez moi je vous en
prie
[Musique]
le 19 janvier
je passe à reims voilà donc venu vous
voir nombreux il ya mon spectacle qui
passe à reims le 19 janvier après
j'attaque longjumeau le 22 je serai à
val de reuil val de reuil 23 janvier le
25 janvier je suis dans la région de
bordeaux je suis même à bordeaux pour
dire pour être plus précis je suis à
bordeaux
n'oubliez pas que sur les écrans de
cinéma en ce moment il ya un film
formidable qui est le film de coline
serreau 1 c'est une femme formidable que
j'aime beaucoup que tu une grande
réalisatrice qui s'appelle la crise avec
de grands comédiens comme vincent lindon
zabou maria pacôme qui fait un numéro
exceptionnel le film marche je vous
entends tapella sur les hommes oui non
mais non là non mais a bien suivi à
chaque fois je vous trouve un port un
bas on a 10 40 secondes
non mais vous avez payé c'est normal
j'ai demandé 41 secondes de promotion
plus encore d'un oui mais enfin vous
avez demandé 40 monde accorde à écouter
je vais y aller parce qu'on m'attend sur
notre démission lors du conseil avant de
partir quand même pour la suite de
l'émission à ce prix là non politique
politique attaqué la politique a fini
avec le comique faut attaquer la
politique d'accords scéno plus gros
concurrents en laponie d'abord attention
vrai le plus gros concurrents ils sont
d'ailleurs très drôle un sous la mairie
cela met un accent là je sais que je
serai plus là c'est bien ça nous a bien
merci
tr 6 super g
[Applaudissements]
moins de trois mois des législatives la
politique fait un retour en force dans
la vie des français
le débat est à nouveau passionnant hier
raymond barre chez bernard pivot
aujourd'hui bernard tapie chez hardi ma
voix si la profession de foi du rheu
ministre de la ville clair précis 30
secondes utile rien à jeter
qu'est ce qui fait marcher la vie qu'est
ce qui fait marcher d'avis que ce qui
fait marginale
j'imaginais
mais qu'est ce qui vous fait marcher moi
je suis large à laloubère
et
alcalines vont d'air que ce 40% de durée
[Musique]
c'était
un politique en france à trois mois des
législatives alors au matin le site là
c'est bien également bien c'est en plus
c'est oui c'est assez drôle quoi il est
sympathique c'est vraiment bien c'est
vrai ça tout de suite là si vous voulez
c'est naturel en plus c'est vraiment
bien que la leçon de justice à sec ce
moment ça ça nous touche en même temps
qu'eux et vous voudriez voir quoi
maintenant cette année là normalement on
va plutôt au liban depuis six mois mois
s'est déroulé à savoir un petit peu
voilà maintenant avec un bon bouquin
quoi six mois au lit ou alors au coin du
feu
voilà un bon feu de bois un facebook
ouais ouais sinon on a fait comme en
malaisie envoyé feu de bois nation on a
tout ce qu'il faut
ben voila je crois que tout le monde
peut se le procurer ce feu de bois c'est
une cassette matt vidéo qui s'appelle le
feu de cheminée sans la corvée de bois
il ya aussi l'aquarium pouvoir chez vous
un aquarium voilà ça vous ça vous va or
face et c'est formidable qui rit je
crois que ça permet aux gens de
redécouvrir les plaisirs de la lecture
je crois que là encore le service public
a bien rempli sa mission
je crois que j'ai quelque chose pour
vous maintenant professeur rollin s'il
vous plaît ce rejet du sensationnel qui
va faire remonter lardy matt hill et on
en est où il est temps après la
politique nous allons maintenant aborder
les problèmes religieux
mais avant de lancer ce sujet je
voudrais vous faire part début de la
rédaction de la revue mat
quant à son authenticité on pense qu'il
est bidonné on se demande si c'est de
l'info ou si c'est de l'intox
j'ai entendu la parole non mais c'était
un faux et je passais dans le quartier
un fonds en tant que je suis là gênant
philippe c'était comme ça c'est une
formule tout le monde en place cette
formule maintenant c'était que nous ça
double jeu c'est fini double jeu et je
peux faire autre chose au tour de magie
annonces ou vachement bien faire un
paquet de clopes
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est pas
bon allez phillips et appellerait ça
quelqu'un je te gêne pas le respect
allez salut de bach salut salut
[Applaudissements]
les soeurs de la sainte famille oeuvre
dans le quartier le plus mal famé de
philadelphie leur orphelinat est
constamment menacée de vol ou de
vandalisme
les cas d'agressions d'enfants sont
fréquents et de nonnes furent même
violée
[Musique]
refusant de renoncer après 80 ans
d'apostolat les soeurs ont découvert
dans l'ancien testament une solution à
leurs problèmes et pour oeil dent pour
dent
[Musique]
comme les moines orientaux du vieux
monastères de shaolin ses soeurs
modernes se sont convertis aux arts
martiaux
[Musique]
voilà
ouais
[Musique]
pour l'instant leur technique est
purement défensives mais si une vie
était en jeu si la chasteté d'une femme
était menacée ces bonnes soeurs auraient
recours à des prises plus énergique
[Musique]
là
nous bâtirons une salle très gentille
m'enfin je suis obligé de vous redire ce
que j'ai dit le mois dernier dans ma
conférence à madrid
tout ça c'est quand même jamais que des
images pré fabriqué ces deux-là concert
voulons donner la vraie vie n'est pas là
voulaient ne remplacerait jamais le vrai
spectacle vrai spectacle c'est le moment
où je sais pas si le banc
c'est un ours qui marche avec des
pigeons sur la tête vous comprenez c'est
le moment où tout d'un coup ça décolle
c'est une autre dimension c'est ça que
les gens demandent jeu l'allemand on a
un ours est ce qu'on peut avoir à nous
avec des pigeons sur la tête
oui mais voilà tu as fait rentrer l'ours
[Musique]
pigeon ce soir alors professeur vraiment
thierry bros
chapeau c'est sûrement juillet à oui
c'est écouter vraiment s'ils voulaient
offrir un verre à votre invité c'est
pour moi c'est ma tournée lescan faut
avoir un petit peu de champagne
notre ami ou madame
[Musique]
tous
mina
elles tiennent madame elle est agressive
éclaircies
[Musique]
moi je
en fait pas je
un seul
merci beaucoup merci macabre est
professeur
[Musique]
il est un peu marre quand même temps tu
te rends pas nous prennent pour des
moutons ça
ben écoute faut pas déconner quand même
une demi heure de merde écoute c simple
mais tais toi mais en soi mais titre oui
bah moi j'en ai marre c'est tout on
n'est pas des moutons canvas assez
applaudi a que dix mètres applaudi mais
tu sais quoi et n'importe quoi il veut
qu'en ce mois faire de 120 pour faire sa
ba dans tu m'excuseras non c'est vrai
que c'est truqué alors vraiment on
allait les jeudis à bondues scudamore
complète la rue c'est truqué c'est de la
mélamine émission de l'esa moi j'en fais
tous les jours
l'hôte avec son feu de bois bientôt elle
frappe hisser son chien avec sa télé ces
nuages allait bien aller laisse tomber
merci un ascenseur à foix tox moon s'est
lui même dit qu'il fallait aller chez
sabbatique
qu'est ce que tu veux tarif est mieux là
bas c'est nul et puis c'est tout
qu'est-ce que je suis athée vigne on
aurait dû être là mais ça sert à rien de
discuter des scouts mamèche alléché
sabbatique chez lui ça va mais c'est toi
qui voulais venir lors d'une autre
revenir sur ce document
merci de venir à notre micro vous avez
là entre autres beautés un très joli
chien à est ce qu'on peut lire bonjour
et horriblement méchant est ce que je
vois ce batman dont il paraît que ceux
qui cherchent vraiment rendez vous près
qu'il le fera je peux me dire je me
penchais pour attention c'est moi qui me
fait peur c'est chez eux et chez
terrible série elle est terriblement
terrible terrible noah ya mieux je suis
très content oui tu dis asie cette
fenêtre puis est tombé j'ai appris qu'un
petit et smallville crunch et à
l'environnement
d'alors thierry vous faites fausse route
notre cible qui est composé
essentiellement de jeunes peu instruits
ne connais pas cette dizaine mansfield
notre cible c'est parler ceux qui
connaissent quelque chose pas faire la
leçon à la fin notre cible qui arrivent
les chiffres le montrent elle attend
qu'on lui parle de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il veut qu'on lui parle de
ce dont tout le monde parle c'est ça
qu'elle attend notre cible ah bon bah
évidemment dracula dracula ok alors le
vernis dracula est sorti mercredi
comme à chaque lancement d'un gros films
américains les médias vous en ont
rebattu les oreilles jour et nuit
j'en dirai pas plus
[Musique]
mais pas celui-là mais tout ça sort ça
j'ai jamais demandé ça j'ai demandé le
dracula de coppola
mais je ne crois pas ça mais je
mais pas celui-là mais c'est encore pas
celui là
mais
m
on
ça fait le troisième que vous mettez
s'est toujours pas le bon c'est ici que
se déroule à l'effroyable et révoltante
histoire du prince d'art accula et de la
femme qu'il aime
j'ai traversé des océans d'éternité pour
vous trouver là
la côte et son premier ministre
mais d'y rester
jamais je n'ai rencontré un homme aussi
épris la vie ne ressemble à nulle autre
[Musique]
ah ah
il existe on va t'on love affrontons
l'heure
je met à mort faisait
à la fois jeune et vieux il peut devenir
brume faveur
pareil
le pouvoir de son désir maléfique est
sans limite
il faudra qu premier c'est son année dû
libérer sa fidèle fanatiques chef et la
concubine du démon
rejoignez moi dans la vie éternelle
votre salut naîtra de sa destruction
mia
parce que pour ça je peux voir comment
voyez vous m
l'émission touche à sa fin il est temps
de faire un petit bilan alors ça vous a
plu
au global manga disais des choses bien
il ya vraiment des t-bonds cia ya du bon
et du moins bon si il ya des avancées
mais le moment je y est peut-être qu'à
des moments où il y aura peut-être via
des baisses quoi tendre ouais mais c'est
probablement voir quoi maintenant à quoi
faut voir la longue évidemment il faut
voir la deuxième fois la confiance faux
voire plusieurs mois
voilà qu'à partir de la deuxième peut
être que ça va comme ça prendre son élan
ouais ça peut intéresser oui ça peut
marcher
enfin le dites moi non mais dites moi je
mange ouais bah les bains nous on fait
avant le samedi soir on regardait choya
ouais bah ouais pas s'envoler c'est
simon moi j'aime bien moi je trouvais
qu'il s'avoue plus délicieux oui c'est
lâche c'est peut-être là découvert les
ventes illégales et de dire ce qui est
oui c'est démissionner du souvent faim
séquences insolites
des expéditions scientifiques françaises
américaines et turc se sont succédé à
coup spain aucune n'a réussi à percer le
mystère des siffleurs ni le lien qui
pourrait exister avec les trois autres
régions du monde l'on utilise aussi la
langue siffler les turcs eux censure que
la langue d'oiseaux a été inventé chez
eux
[Musique]
à l'étoile à paris pierre dans la
lumière à l'étudier à l'époque personne
ne sait quand et pourquoi on a commencé
à siffler dans cette vallée c'est ainsi
la vie à cusco il commence et finit par
des sifflements
[Musique]
c'est notre deuxième langue maternelle
distille les enfants la connaissent
avant de savoir parler on peut tout se
dire en sifflant tout ce qui fait la vie
quotidienne on se dispute on s'insulte
en sifflant
puis
les sifflements porte plus loin que la
voie jusqu'à deux kilomètres et demi et
couvre le tumulte de la rivière c'est
ainsi que l'on annonce de maison en
maison les naissances ou les morts
[Musique]
tous
m
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu